rendez vous à tout de suite il est
consacré à la guerre en ukraine et à sa
conséquence directe sur l'afflux de
réfugiés un afflux historiques déjà deux
millions de personnes c'est du jamais vu
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale hugo
lemonnier
hommes et femmes de tout âge force et
d'affronter l'hiver
la fuite des civils ukrainien continue
comme ici à l'ouest de la capitale
ça fait trois jours sans eau sans
électricité sans chauffage les stocks
sont presque vides les petits enfants
l'ont supporté jusqu'à maintenant on ne
voulait pas partir on espérait que ça se
termine rapidement coin de champ en
quelques jours près de dix mille
personnes ont quitté ces deals près de
kiev selon l'onu 2 millions d'ukrainiens
auraient déjà fui leur pays
j'ai laissé toute ma vie derrière et
j'espère que je pourrai y retourner je
veux pouvoir rentrer chez moi un jour
bac rang - t à elle seule la pologne
accueille plus de la moitié des civils
ukrainien
voyez la file s'allonge
parfois il y a deux fois plus de monde
et parfois mois mais les gens arrivent
en continu et
en france 5000 ukrainiens seraient
arrivés sur le territoire une partie
serait en transit mais d'autres se
préparent à trouver refuge ici je
constate que beaucoup de ces
d'ukrainiens m'ont manifesté tout de
suite leur désir de vouloir travailler
et de vouloir s'insérer mais en même
temps bien entendu notre objectif commun
le leur et le nôtre c'est qu'il puisse
retourner le plus vite possible chez eux
évidemment dès que les les conditions le
permettront à terme l'union européenne
s'attend à accueillir jusqu'à 5 millions
de réfugiés ukrainien du jamais vu sur
le continent depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale
et on en débat tout de suite avec mes
invités galia ackerman bonsoir soir venu
de vous retrouver et historienne
traductrice spécialiste de la russie et
vous publiez le régime aux immortels la
guerre sacrée de poutine aux éditions
premier parallèle christian lequesne
bonsoir professeur à sciences po
spécialiste des questions européennes
votre livre la puissance par l'image les
états et leur diplomatie publique c'est
aux presses de sciences po justement
pierre henry bonsoir vous accueillir
vous êtes le président de france
fraternité je commence avec vous et ce
chiffre de 2 millions d'ukrainiens qui a
été annoncé par le hcr le haut
commissariat de l'onu aux réfugiés
peut-être beaucoup plus d'ailleurs dans
ces prochaines semaines
le chiffre est historique question
penser que la réponse de l'union
européenne on parlera de la france un
peu plus en détail dans un instant la
réponse de l'union européenne est rapide
et elle est adaptée à la situation
extraordinaire que nous vivons à nos
frontières
il ya une règle absolue lorsque survient
une catastrophe une guerre les gens vont
d'abord à proximité de chez eux parce
que ils ont toujours l'espoir de pouvoir
retourner très rapidement et donc
aujourd'hui on voit que ce sont les pays
limitrophes à
l'ukraine qui sont particulièrement à la
fois généreux est impactée c'est
évidemment la pologne et la hongrie ses
draps et puis il ya une autre règle
c'est que les personnes iront dans les
pays où il y a des diasporas déjà
constitués et de ce point de vue les
iront principalement d'abord en
allemagne
ils iront en espagne environ en italie
où il y à une communauté déjà constitués
et vous remarqué que en ce qui concerne
la france le chiffre est
extrêmement faible cinq mille personnes
sur 2 millions de personnes déjà
déplacées
par contre il faudra évidemment
travailler sur la question de
l'intégration parce que beaucoup des
personnes qui arrivent aujourd'hui
resteront à mon avis
durablement
ses je ne dirais pas la même chose des
gens qui se tiennent en bordure du
conflit donc il y a une réponse de
protection temporaire qui s'applique à
tous les ukrainiens qui sont partis
également aux résidents réguliers sur le
territoire ukrainien avant le 24 février
d'actes déclenchement et puis il y à une
incertitude sur les personnes qui
avaient des courts séjours
travailleurs et étudiants et il faudra
voir quelle est la réponse de protection
que chaque pays européen donnera parce
qu' un certain nombre d'entre eux ne
peuvent retourner chez eux dans de
bonnes conditions galia ackerman il ya
beaucoup de femmes il ya beaucoup de
d'enfants parmi ces c s'est réfugié il
faut peut-être expliquer pourquoi parce
que les hommes qui voulaient quitter le
pays ne n'avais pas forcément la
possibilité et on leur disait il faut
vous restiez pour défendre ukraine non
le précédent lnsq est prononcée déclarer
la mobilisation générale
donc les hommes entre 18 je crois 60 ans
ne doivent pas quitter le pays et pour
beaucoup de gens même au delà de 60 ans
il ya beaucoup de gens qui restent parce
qu'ils peuvent quand même être utile et
peut-être il ne se bat pas dans les
unités de défense territoriale sont pas
intégrés à l'armée
mais j'en connais parmi mes amis qui
essaie d'aider les réfugiés d'organiser
les départs d'organiser le
ravitaillement etc sera donc chacun
compte mais bien sûr une grande partie
mais je ne dis pas du tout
majoritairement une grande partie de
deux femmes jeunes avec des familles les
enfants en bas âge
infinie parce qu' il est impossible de
se terrer dans les sous sols souvent
sans eau sans toilettes sans
ravitaillement donc ceux qui peuvent
parts vous vous l'avez évoqué les
chiffres précis donné par le hcr de deux
de ses de ces réfugiés effectivement la
pologne c'est vraiment le premier pays
d'accueil aujourd'hui un million plus
d'un million deux cent mille personnes
ensuite la hongrie est à moins de 200
milles la slovaquie autour de 140
moldavie roumanie etc etc christian
lequesne cette répartition elle
s'explique aussi par par l'histoire
d'une certaine version par les liens
historiques entre entre ces pays
notamment l'ukraine et la pologne ont
bien sûr il ya des liens historiques
absolument évident il ya de nombreuses
familles en pologne dont les grands
parents parents sont nés voir sont
enterrés en dans le territoire actuel de
de l'ukraine et il y a aussi le
phénomène qui a été mentionné tout à
l'heure de la diaspora c'est à dire que
healy a vraisemblablement avant
l'arrivée des réfugiés déjà plus d'un
million de l'ukrainien qui travaillent
qui travaillent en pologne tout le
secteur de la construction par exemple
aujourd'hui en europe centrale et
orientale est très largement occupé par
par les ukrainiens c'est vrai aussi en
république tchèque si vous faites
construire une maison à prague vous avez
de grandes chances pour que les ouvriers
de votre chantier soit des choix des
ukrainiens et donc je rebondis aussi sur
la question de la réponse européenne à
gagner ackermann il est évident mais
s'il faut mieux le dire qu'il faut
effectivement tenir compte des pays
europe où il ya déjà une diaspora
ukrainienne ça va pas ce pardon c'est un
peu triviale mais ce se dispatcher les
réfugiés d'une façon un peu arbitraire
bien sûr et vous savez au sein de
l'union européenne en effet les
quantités les quantités de gens qui ont
des permis de séjour qui ont acquis
entre temps la nationalité de tel ou tel
pays c'était très inégale par exemple en
france autant que je sache il n'ya que
quelque chose comme dix huit 18 mai de
de gens avec des permis de séjour plus
probablement une certaine quantité
quelques milliers qui ont ils déjà la
nationalité française plus des
travailleurs illégaux
dans le secteur de construction pour les
hommes et dans le secteur des soins à la
personne pour les femmes mais donc les
gens qui arrivent imaginez que presque
personne ne connaît le français donc ils
vont pas aller dans le pays où une wii
il n'y a pas de famille et dont ils ne
connaissent pas la langue en comparaison
il ya beaucoup plus du crâne et en
italie par exemple oui parce que
l'italie à une autre politique en italie
si disons une femme qui s'occupe des
soins à la personne obtient un travail
on lui donne le titre de séjour c'est ça
va dans l'autre sens et je crois si vous
me contre sociaux mme contredisait qu'il
ya quelque chose comme plus de 200 mille
deux cent trente six mille en italie
fait 120 mille ans
n'y était déjà là qui était déjà cent
mille
grande bretagne je vous pose la question
sur la façon dont ça va se passer est ce
qu'il ya quand même un risque que je ne
vais pas être caricatural mais que
l'administration européenne face à un
peu sans tenir compte de ses diasporas
ou pas non parce que le principe de
protection temporaire ne repose sur une
double volonté priori celle d état
d'accueillir et puis salle des personnes
et donc
c'est ce que nous disions tout à l'heure
les personnes iront d'abord là où il y à
proximité avec l'ukraine et là où il y à
une diaspora donc la répartition dans un
premier temps elle va se faire
j'allais dire va s'organiser sur le
terrain là où ça va devenir compliqué
c'est si cette affaire dure parce que
bien évidemment le choc pour les
économies polonaise ambroise est très
important et donc il faudra une
solidarité très forte de la part des
autres pays de l'union c'est ce que l'on
a vu dans d'autres conflits si vous
prenez le conflit syrien où sont allés
les personnes d'abord au liban en
jordanie en en turquie et donc elles
mêmes phénomènes se reproduisent a mis
en allemagne oui un million
ouvre ses portes alors les laetitia
vouliez
revenir sur une image d'une actualité
qui étaient apparues sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'a été ensuite diffusée un peu
partout là la difficulté pour les
expatriés africains au nord africains de
passer la frontière oui ce sont d'abord
des images et des témoignages qui
spontanée ingres ont été diffusées par
les personnes qui étaient là ont été
empêchés de passer la frontière et puis
ensuite les médias s'en sont occupés
sont allés voir ont recueilli des
témoignages et puis des communiqués de
diplomates deux chefs d'état par exemple
macky sall le président du sénégal ou
alors le président de la commission de
l'union africaine la semaine dernière
ensemble ils ont fait paraître un
communiqué où ils se disent préoccupés
par les informations rapportées selon
lesquelles les citoyens africains se
trouvant du côté ukrainien de la
frontière se verrait refuser le droit de
la traversée alors après tout ces
alertes évidemment les médias français
ont fait leur travail d'investigation
la fp est également parti recueillir des
témoignages comme celui ci on va
l'écouter jean jacques et qui est
étudiant congolais
nous sommes allés à la frontière de les
traîner la pologne en tout cas c'est
compliqué surtout pour nous les
étrangers dépasser les étrangers
africains nous avons des problèmes pour
passer un privilège c'est normal qu'on
privilégie les femmes et les enfants
mais les hommes nous restons du matin au
soir on passe la nuit sous la fraîcheur
des boues
il n'ya pas manger il n'ya pas pourquoi
on est des bons on a fait plus de quatre
jours sans rien manger le phénomène
existe mais c'est pas si facile d'en
mesurer l'ampleur non ce n'est pas
simple parce que déjà nous sommes ici
donc moi je me garderai bien de vous
dire si c'est un phénomène d'ampleur ou
pas mais simplement je suis allé
chercher depuis une dizaine de jours
pour avoir déjà les témoignages de
journalistes qui sont sur place les
correspondants du monde et de libération
nuancent leurs conclusions en disant oui
c'est vrai que c'est cela existe mais
comme disait jean jacques là à l'instant
c'est parce qu'il ya souvent deux fils
une file femmes enfants qui sont
prioritaires et les autres qui attendent
à côté donc oui ça existe oui monsieur
je vous donnerai la parole ça existe et
ajuste charles michel dimanche qui prend
la parole charles michel je rappelle
qu'ils président du conseil européen et
qui accuse carrément la russie de
propagande c'est à dire que comme
ils ont instrumentalisé si vous voulez
le problème est que ces images thomas
c'est qu'il ya énormément d'émotion
naturel immédiate humaine donc bien sûr
qu' il y a toujours des tentatives d'un
côté comme de l'autre d'instrumentaliser
les images et donc charles michel 10 et
condamne la russie pour ces faits de
propagande pierre henri georges de votre
place de présente france fait sa
fraternité j'imagine que des
informations et vous avez dû en avoir
vérifié que quelle est l'ampleur de ce
phénomène ce nom ce phénomène existe
ouais
difficile difficile évidemment
de le mesurer mais il est clair que les
alertes que nous avons produit les uns
et les autres ong et la frontière et
cédera ont quand même permis de
débloquer la situation mais je vais vous
dire ce n'est pas très nouveau il n'ya
pas d'étonnement
au mois de février au mois de décembre
dernier vous aviez des morts des
réfugiés qui mouraient à la frontière
entre la pologne et la biélorussie
il avait simplement si j'ose dire et si
je puis me permettre l'inconvénient
d'être kurdes
voilà donc
pas rien on met les pieds dans le plat
mais ça veut dire que ça veut dire que
si on est blanc et chrétien c'est plus
facile de passer la frontière bah oui
oui oui tout simplement et puis je vous
rappelle tout simple aussi que l'ukraine
n'avait pas une politique d'ouverture à
l'égard des réfugiés très très forte
j'ai regardé les statistiques
pour 2020 et 550 demandes de protection
en ukraine en 2020 il y en a eu 374
refusé donc tout ça évidemment dans un
contexte qu'il ne faut pas
instrumentaliser la russie évidemment
fait de la propagande mais ces
discriminations ont eu lieu et je crois
que les alertes ont permis quand même de
faire en sorte qu'elle
s'est émue oui sinon je crois qu'on a on
a tout à fait raison d'être d'être
prudent parce que je suis sûr qu'il ya
des actes de solidarité absolument
formidable de la part des slovaques des
polonais à l'égard des africains ou des
ou des asiatiques mais en règle générale
nous savons quand même que les sociétés
d'europe centrale ont encore un problème
avec l'altérité culturelle c'est à dire
le monde non européens et ça ça provient
de 2 de leur histoire finalement il n'y
a pas eu dans le dans le bloc communisme
au temps des migrations autant de
brassage inter interculturel y avait
bien sûr quelques étudiants de ce qu'on
appelait les pays frères à l'époque dans
l'est et dans les pays d'europe centrale
et orientale et dont il ya un problème
qu'on a qu'on a d'ailleurs très bien vu
au moment où monsieur juncker avait
proposé une répartition par quota des
syriens aider les afghans là il ya eu
une fermeture des pays du v6 rade
absolument publique tchèque pologne
hongrie il ya même eu un une déclaration
d'un premier ministre slovaque qui a dit
nous voulons bien quelques syrien mais à
condition qu'ils soient chrétiens voilà
et ça c'est condamner aussi par tout un
tas d'intellectuels dans ces sociétés
mais c'est une tendance quand même de
ces de ces sociétés d'europe centrale
assez lourde alors on va maintenant
ouvrir le chapitre plus détaillées sur
la réponse français je vous l'avais dit
à ce chiffre nombre de réfugiés et
craignent en france depuis le début du
conflit on est à cinq milles et quentin
calme et je vous propose de nous
rejoindre de nouveau puisque rebond soit
quentin le ministre de l'intérieur était
auditionné sur ce thème au sénat cet
après midi exactement ils étaient
auditionnés par deux commissions
permanentes du sénat la commission des
lois la commission des affaires
européennes pendant une heure et demie
la plus détaillée comme ça un petit peu
les chiffres dont il disposait et il a
donné ce chiffre de 5000 ukrainien
recensés depuis le début de la guerre en
ukraine sur le territoire français un
chiffre qui est peut-être sous-estimé a
dit le ministre car eh bien on utilise
uniquement lé passeport biométrique pour
les comptes et donc 1 à peut-être
davantage at il dit les ukrainiens pour
la plupart rejoignent leurs familles en
grande bretagne ou dans le sud de
l'europe comme vous l'avez déjà un peu
évoquée sur ce plateau car il n'y a en
france a dit ministre que dix sept mille
ukrainien la pop diaspora ukrainienne en
france une population donc assez modeste
par rapport à d'autres pays de l'union
européenne il ya un point de tension qui
a fait l'objet d'une partie entière de
l'audition de gérald darmanin c'est les
tensions avec la grande bretagne car il
ya des familles environ 300 personnes
qui se sont vu refuser l'accès à la
grande bretagne depuis la semaine
dernière écoutez gérald darmanin à ce
propos à ce propos à peu près 600
ukrainiens se sont présentés à la
frontière britannique a calé trois cents
ont été refoulés dont une très grande
majorité de femmes et d'enfants
pourquoi parce que
les britanniques ne sont pas dans
l'espace schengen sont sortis évidemment
de l'union européenne au sens politique
du terme et donc n'implique pas la
protection temporaire tel que nous
l'avons voté la ministre britannique
semblait comprendre la difficulté est
donc m'avait fait part de sa volonté
d'installer à calais des personnes
britannique de son gouvernement capable
de pouvoir résoudre ces questions
nous n'avons pas eu pour l'instant gain
de cause voilà une situation à calais
que gérald darmanin espère voir évoluer
favorablement dans les prochains jours
avec un un consulat qui pourrait être
installé à la frontière autre point
important évoqué dans cette audition du
ministre thomas c'est l'accueil des 5000
réfugiés donc que l'on a recensé on a ce
chiffre donné depuis ce matin sur le
nombre de places disponibles pour leur
accueil il y en aurait au total 10 1798
comme vous voyez sur cette animation
5978 j'aurais bien mis en place par des
particuliers
3683 par les collectivités locales et
1137 par les grands opérateurs
d'hébergement alors les sénateurs ont
interrogé le gouvernement comment se
fait-il qu'ils aient une part aussi
faible de la l'effort de l'état a su
écouter la réponse de gérald darmanin
lorsque j'indique à 3700 places
proposées par une collectivité est en
grande partie ce soit des places d'état
soit les places payées par l'état je
prends l'exemple d'une commune que je
connais bien c'est de tourcoing où vous
dès aujourd'hui d'ailleurs parce qu'il
faut décharger calais d'une partie du
kenya qui attendent les visas de la part
des britanniques ben voilà le préfet a
répondu à la demande de la fin à l'appel
de la maire de tourcoing qui a dit nous
on a un hôtel et cdma l'état qui paiera
des places de cette hausse est de 7
hôtels il se peut qu'ils dansaient placé
chose qui retienne stricto sensu aux
collectivités locales je pense
des logements d'urgence que vous les
avez évoqué ou des gymnases mais ça
c'est une possibilité en cas de grandes
difficultés voilà gérald darmanin quiet
dit surveiller la situation tous les
deux jours avec des arrivées de réfugiés
qu'on annonce exponentielle at il dit
c'est le mot qui là qu'il a eu et qu'il
a employés marlène schiappa est chargée
en particulier de suivre ce dossier avec
même un préfet qui a été mis en place
spécialement un dernier mot thomas pour
dire qu'il ya un site internet qui a été
mis en place depuis ce matin pour que
chacun chacun d'entre nous puisse
apporter son aide à son petit niveau
c'est à l'adresse je m'engage pour
l'ukraine 1 fota baisses allant google
on tombe sur la page du gouvernement
merci beaucoup merci quant à calmer pour
pour toutes ces informations
pierre-henri sur sur les places
d'hébergement est ce que est ce que vous
êtes aussi optimiste que le ministre de
l'intérieur il ya une mobilisation dans
le pays qui fait que en tout cas dans
les prochaines semaines il n'y aura pas
de difficultés la difficulté elle est
plutôt sur le long terme vous avez un
dispositif national d'accueil toutes
nationalités qui est aujourd'hui
quasiment saturés qui est occupé à 97%
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous avez vu tout à l'heure qu'il n'y
avait qu'un peu plus de 1000 places
disponibles chez les grands opérateurs
de l'état mais où c'est quand l'état
faire
il fait donc nous il y a la volonté
politique et je ne doute pas un instant
que les personnes seront prises en
charge après la grande difficulté c'est
la place que l'on trouve dans penser que
c'est une arrivée exponentielle qu'en
fait non je ne le crois pas pour toutes
les raisons que nous avons souligné tout
à l'heure mais il faut qu'on s'entend de
10000 quinze mille vingt mille personnes
rapidement ça peut provoquer quelques
difficultés compte tenu de notre
organisation mais sur le moyen terme
nous serons nous nous saurons faire la
grande difficulté j'insiste c'est
l'accès à l'emploi c'est parler la
langue c'est
qu'on va retrouver avec les réfugiés
ukrainien tous les phénomènes que nous
rencontrons avec les autres réfugiés qui
ne parlent pas la langue qui ont pas
forcément toujours les formations
adéquates et ça va prendre du temps et
donc il faut que la société française
aussi sache que au delà de l'émotion
légitime qui nous travaillent tôt ce qui
nous unit qui qui nous prend aux tripes
eh bien il va falloir travailler sur le
long terme galia ackerman les réfugiés
c'est aussi une arme pour poutine ne
faut pas l'oublier a notamment dans les
négociations je pense parce que vous
savez aujourd'hui
les autorités russes
l'armée russe a déclaré qu'il ouvrait
des couloirs humanitaires de 8h à 16h
mais uniquement vers la russie
et là il n'ya pas foule à la différence
des frontières occidentales
parce que en effet s'il ya un afflux de
beaucoup de réfugiés en russie qui
simplement fui les combats et qui n'ont
pas la possibilité d'aller ailleurs est
ce que vous imaginez une maison de
quartier au nord arrivés jusqu'à une
frontière occidentale
maintenant que toutes les belles russie
est aussi fermé ces temps très long
périple et
quand il ya des combats en plus c'est
quelque chose d'un principe câble donc
il ya beaucoup de gens actuellement qui
se taire quand même dans les refuges
dans les caves c'est rare et qui quand
même ne veulent pas faire
ce faire évacuer vers la russie parce
qu'ensuite ça peut devenir un outil de
chantage
dans les négociations qui est quand même
un total faute à négocier aussi et bien
sûr aimé c'est quoi la stratégie de
vladimir poutine sur sur cette question
des réfugiés qui reviennent vers la
russie il a il a un objectif je pense
qu'il peut avoir un objectif d'ailleurs
le même que pour le de même que pour les
crimes et la russie depuis quelques
années souffre d'un déficit
démographique assez important il ya eu
en plus le colis qui s'est superposée
est en fait
si on compte non pas les chiffres qui
sont avancés par les agences officielles
concernant le coc vide mais la
surmortalité
on arrive à plus d'un million de
personnes donc pour la russie qui veut
occuper l'espace de plus en plus grands
avoir de moins en moins de population
c'est quelque chose de mauvais donc
peut-être que la russie puisque il
s'agit de régions russophones compte les
installer les assimiler voir les
utiliser ensuite contre l'ukraine
voilà
le projet et si vous permettez j'ajoute
juste un mot pour
le débat précédent moi je pense que nous
avons vu tous les chiffres actuellement
ceux qui sont en france il ya plus que
la moitié après 60 % qui sont accueillis
par des familles mais il faut dire je
connais assez bien cette diaspora
ukrainienne récente la plupart vivent
dans des logements exigus eux ont pu
bénéficier même de logements sociaux ce
sont des gens qui travaillent dur et je
ne vois pas comment un long terme ne
peuvent accueillir des familles entières
donc je pense que la crise n'a pas
encore commencé mais elles risquent de
commencer un peu plus tard dans ces
familles d'accueil ne pourront plus
assumer je voudrais rester maintenant on
va vraiment terminer ce débat autour de
la stratégie de l'avenir poutine mais
mais toujours sur cette question des
réfugiés puis alors je me tourne vers
vous sur les corridas ou les couloirs
humanitaires il faut quand même se
souvenir de ce que poutine peut en faire
et de ce qu'il en a fait dans d'autres
conflits c'est absolument cesser une
promesse non tenue c'est c'est du
chantage c'est parfois des bombardements
sur des sur des routes qui sont censé
être sécurisé et enfin c'est tout ça
mais au delà des couloirs humanitaires
ce qui à quoi il faut aboutir c'est un
cessez le feu parce que le couloir
humanitaire c'est pas simplement un
endroit où transitent les personnes pour
être évacués
éventuellement vers les pays de l'union
européenne ou vers la russie c'est aussi
un endroit où on achemine des vivres ou
en achemine du matériel sanitaire et
pour l'instant les conditions n'y sont
absolument pas et puis d'une certaine
façon
admettre le couloir humanitaire c'est
admettre aussi la catastrophe
humanitaire qui est en train de se
dérouler autour d'un certain nombre de
villes donc
vraiment ce qu'il convient de demander
aujourd'hui c'est l'arrêt des hostilités
est d'ailleurs poutine lui-même dit
j'obtiendrai je tiendrai mes objectifs
que ce soit par la guerre ou par la
négociation peut-être que le temps de la
négociation
pourrait venir
des raisons mais ça veut dire que aussi
celle un ski droit à un moment donné
accepter d'être autour des biens bien
dans des outils d'aujourd'hui on va
parler de la stratégie dernière petite
baie effectivement je vous propose
d'entendre le président la république
emmanuel macron alors qu'ils étaient à
la fois président et candidat ça ça va
être notre notre lot d'observateur
pendant les les semaines qui viennent
qu'il était à à poissy dans les yvelines
la ville du maire karl olive pour un
débat face à des français triés sur le
volet et voilà ce qu'il disait d'eux
vladimir poutine là c'était plutôt le
président qui s'exprimait oui nous
continuerons à parler à la russie alors
la discussion est difficile avec le
président poutine parce qu'aujourd'hui
il refuse le cessez-le-feu parce
qu'aujourd'hui la russie est sur une
position très simple qui est de demander
des conditions très dures à l'ukraine et
ça c'est une discussion entre les
ukrainiens et les russes mais qui se
fait dans des conditions
très inéquitable c'est pour moi la clé
l'immense responsabilité aujourd'hui que
prend le président poutine c'est celle
de combattre un peuple qui lui est frère
et de vouloir le détruire et l'humilier
avec les pires terme
et ça c'est une faute historique
christian lequesne est ce que vous êtes
d'accord sur cette formulation une faute
historique de la part de blaignan petit
oui tout à fait je pense que la guerre à
laquelle nous nous assistons est une
guerre fratricide et je pense que la
résistance
des ukrainiens aujourd'hui à l'invasion
est telle que même si la victoire
militaire qui
consisterait à contrôler une partie du
territoire
techniquement ce fait le peuple
ukrainien ne cédera pas ne cédera pas il
ya une
conscience aujourd'hui
nationale en ukraine qui est plus forte
que que jamais et nous nous parlions
dans un précédent débat il ya quelques
quelques jours
avec gallien kerman 2
du rôle que pourrait jouer ce parti des
régions et qui pourrait être la
cinquième colonne parce que c'est le
parti russophone etc on ne l'entend pas
totalement pour l'instant ils n'osent
plus s'exprimer on n'ose pas on n'ose
plus aujourd'hui en ukraine manière que
l'on éprouve s'asseyait à carmat oui
tout à fait le parti des régions
a disparu on sait même pas où se
trouvent ses chefs et je crois que plus
personne pratiquement n'ose dire que il
faut s'aider qui à la grande russie ses
traits et ses trains c'est à dire que le
10 mai routine élite arriver à un
résultat exactement inverse deux de ses
espoirs ils pensaient probablement que
vous savez il ya toute une rhétorique
issu de la seconde guerre mondiale déjà
on parle pas de la guerre mais on parle
quand même de libérer l'ukraine on
utilise le mot libéré comme jadis
l'armée soviétique libérer l'europe et
donc est donc apparemment ils espéraient
que le peuple libéré de la junte
fasciste nazi va les accueillir avec les
fleurs et ben non alors il ya une
dimension et je je je reste avec vous
gagnez ackermann parce que il ya une
dimension qui est vraiment intéressant
sur peut-être une stratégie de poutine
qui pourrait être une stratégie de
partitions de l'ukraine et qui repose
sur alors des réalités ou des fantasmes
historique d'ailleurs si vous pouvez
nous les rappeler oui bien sûr vous
savez en fait tout était déjà clair le
21 février à trois jours du début des
hostilités
quand vladimir poutine a prononcé son
discours entre guillemets historique
mais ses intentions et ont été exprimés
avec beaucoup de clarté et
je vous rappelle qu'en fait il y avait
deux parties dans ce discours même
peut-être trois parties on peut dire il
y avait une partie un très long
développement sur l'ukraine avec des
mensonges historiques
ensuite et avec la deuxième partie sur
le temps
qui était très menaçante et donc parfois
je me dis que cette partie n'était pas
pour rien dans ce discours peut être
qu'ils comptent ensuite s'attaquer même
à ses anciens satellites qui sont
membres de l'otan et ensuite une
troisième partie méthode courte 2
minutes sur le donne pas ce qui là qu'il
a acquis qu'il venait de le reconnaître
mais alors sur la première voilà il est
d'origine parce que ce que j'ai compris
c'est que il justifie
il y réécrit l'histoire de l'ukraine en
10 ans et la russie alors soit la russie
tsariste soit la russie soviétique qui
vous a donné ses terres c'est ça en
quelque sorte en quelque sorte il y
avait même une carte qui a été fait ou
on disait cette partie de l'ukraine
le sud est c'est le cadeau de l' empire
des tsars
la partie occidentale c'est le cadeau de
staline la partie nord avec carte yves
c'est le cadeau de lénine est donc
finalement
il restait au centre un petit territoire
comme ça bien sûr sans aucune sortie
vers les mers et c'est rare qui on peut
dire il considère que le cren historique
c'est-à-dire le crâne des impôts rock
des kazakhs et sera donc libre et les
ide a en effet les idées d'une partition
de l'ukraine pour en finir une fois pour
toutes dans leur tête c'est de
transformer cet état en
plus tôt ou quatre centres un petit état
petit état avec des régimes favorables
au kremlin et donc restaurer
7,7
comment dirais-je cette situation
historique mais mais en fait
c'est peut-être un peu long à expliquer
mais en fait tout cela est entièrement
faux il faut conclure je sais qu'on
voudra concluant mais j'ai juste une
question parce que vous dites
effectivement il a été surpris il
pensait faire une guerre éclair ils tous
ont finalement une résistance en ukraine
d'accord mais il n'est toujours pas
arrêté personne la stopper on ne sait
pas si les sanctions vont stopper on
sait que l'europe ne veut pas entrer en
guerre donc est ce que vous ne pensez
pas in fine et que on laisse peut être
pour christian lequesne l'ukraine à la
russie est allé christian lequesne avait
dit non mais je suis je suis d'accord
l'europe ne veut pas entrer en guerre ça
c'est absolument
et l'otan quand on dit l'europe c'est
l'union européenne et l'otan est
également d'ailleurs on évite les ce cas
là mais on évite l'escaladent aussi
parce que poutine ne cesse de dire à
partir du moment où vous vous engagez
d'une quelconque manière nous
considérons que vous serez belligérants
et donc voilà c'est lui qui fait monter
les enchères voyez c'est là c'est une
très grande différence avec prague 1968
lorsque les chars du pacte de varsovie
sont entrés en tchécoslovaquie en 68
l'ambassadeur d'union soviétique à
l'époque à washington est allé voir les
américains et leur a dit vous savez
c'est une affaire interne au pacte de
varsovie donc quelque part il a protégé
le conflit possible avec les occidentaux
là on n'est pas du tout dans ce cas de
figure pas du tout c'est très très
différents et vous voyez le lit des
mêmes
j'entendais cette idée américaine
que des avions polonais pourrait être
repeint aux couleurs de l'ukraine est
ensuite donnée à l'armée de l'air
ukrainienne ça pourrait être considérée
il pourrait y avoir une interprétation
de poutine disant c'est une forme
d'entrer en guerre donc on est obligé de
faire très très très très attention en
raison du caractère extrêmement
belliqueux aussi à l'égard de l'ouest à
l'égard de l'occident c'est une c'est
une revanche contre l'occident aussi
mêlé ackermann je crains que quoi que
nous fassions
ou quoi que nous ne fassions pas
s'il admire poutine a le projet et nous
ne savons pas quel est son projet voilà
en avant qu'il n'entre en guerre on
pensait que le conflit était possible
mais qu'au pire il occuperait encore une
partie du donbass ou peut-être ray en
couloir entre d'un crime et la
transnistrie
mais entre le débat si la transnistrie
mais on ne pensait pas qu'ils attaquent
frontalement tout le cren et qu'il veut
en faire en fait écrasé dans des mots
clés l'état ukrainien mais est ce que
nous savons quelle est la totalité de
son projet je dis encore une fois ce
n'est pas pour rien que la deuxième
partie de ce discours où il me semble il
a plus ou moins toutes annoncées
c'était c'était le temps la nécessité de
revenir à la situation d'avant d'avant
1997 c'est à dire enlever les armements
américains enlevés les bases militaires
de toute l'europe de l'est centrale
neutralité
qualifié d' une moitié de l'europe et
donc nous ne savons toujours pas s'il
n'a pas le projet puisqu'il n'a pas
réussi par la négociation
de
procéder par la force merci beaucoup
merci à tous galia ackerman le régiment
immortel la guerre sacrée de poutine
édition premier parallèle et christian
lequesne la puissance par l'image les
états et leur diplomatie publique aux
presses de sciences po merci encore à
participer à ce débat je vous dis merci
laetitia à demain